are they on the phone now yeah that's
great Leon you know that's really
terrific you talk to me with them on the
phone that's really smart
well I don't have a choice what am I
supposed to do I mean they're standing
all around me there's 7,000 [ __ ] cops
all around me who's on the phone now
don't lay it on me I'm not laying it on
you but you do you knew that was going
on right what are you talking about
Maynard on you you knew what was
happening right yeah yeah well I was on
the way I wonder who's on the phone now
am I ready Moretti he saying you on the
phone hello
was somebody talk to me somebody gonna
talk to me or what they on the phone now
they won't talk to you
I like he didn't do it okay he had
nothing to do with it all right
get the [ __ ] off the phone are you off
the phone yeah I was terrific Lee and I
really are convinced them that's what
they wanted to know right did I do it
for you or what yeah yeah thank thank
you very much so now what what are you
gonna do well I thought uh I thought
that I would go back to the hospital you
know that they're really nice there I
mean they really seem like they're
trying to help me so then that's good
then might you fan some yeah well I
don't know if I have a knot so are you
gonna still have the operation yeah yeah
so then what do I spell one of my spots
- Sadie
thanks a lot
and Bob wash yeah see you sometime yeah
I'll see you in my dreams huh oh no you
know life's so funny
you said a mouthful sweetheart
well goodbye huh
all right